over a year ago I made a video called
the worst game on Steam and I went
through the games that are available on
Steam and I looked for what was the
lowest rated that was not a game
intentionally made to be bad and I
landed on the game called skyscraper
simulator which was a very bad game not
because the game was broken no the game
worked fine it's just that there was no
gameplay there was nothing to do even
doing it wasn't satisfying because it's
supposed to be about building
skyscrapers and yet it wasn't but
somehow since the posting of my video it
is gone from 6% to 11% that's almost a
100% increase that is an incredible
improvement and I don't think it's
because there's been a patch to the game
no I don't I don't think so
still psychological horror and horror it
was a very bad game but there are more
bad games I've looked through again and
I've checked out some of these games
some of them are just really poorly made
like new life new life is supposed to be
like almost a role-playing multiplayer
game trying to be Grand Theft Auto RP
but fallen short this is the first
comment to the game and it is not really
worth buying pros none cons the game
itself is a con don't spend your money
on this game go buy a large burger very
good life simulator just like my own
life a big nothing 0-0 wouldn't refund
again pros easy to flip your car you can
run underwater you can gain money when
you buy stuff cons it's easy to flip
your car you can run underwater you can
gain money when you buy stuff conclusion
I think it's too early for an early
access didn't blew up my PC so chill
give the devs a break received the
product for free so that's a bad game
that's made poorly but it's not
necessarily the game that I want to
showcase here so I've sorted by it
lowest rated at the bottom of the list
inseams games right now is a game called
an airport simulator 2014
lexy and put me drifting half opacity
across the screen in multiple cuts and
different angles
[Music]
okay this game has an eleven percent
which is pretty low but that also is the
current rating of skyscraper simulator
are they people no but these people make
a lot this simulator games blaster
simulator blasts like a pro blasts like
a pro anyway
Airport simulator 11% oh oh boy that is
a thorough review I paid a pound for it
during a Christmas sale a while back I
could have gone to pound land bought
Pepsi instead it probably would have
putted more enjoyment why God have you
made us suffer like this
if we're going based on games that also
match up to the standard we have before
we have a game called race to Mars which
sits at the calamitous percent o 6% and
you'd think race to Mars that sounds
super cool I can't even believe that
that would be that bad a No a perfect
example of why early access has a bad
reputation
there have been no updates as of the
time of this review for three months the
game in its present state is unplayable
if you are a fan of this genre don't buy
now check the game in six months time to
see if it is developed at all posted
October 7 2014
I'm guessing there has not been an
update pretty steamy pile over here from
the first time I played it when 9%
interest on a 1 million dollar loan was
10 million dollars - now when it freezes
every third month things have gotten no
better hey at least there are a few
views of the water in the background
right you know the ocean I dumped my $20
in - it's a great screensaver years
later game has been banded from
developer to developer and remains -
placeholder art literally there is no
game here and we have had no updates for
six months save yourselves the money go
outside and jump you'll have a chance to
but this this one it is obviously
terrible but it does not meet my
criteria because it is obviously not a
game that actually were
so it is not what I'm looking for I'm
looking for the worst game that is
actually a game and I have this to tell
you there is a game called Jurassic
Island the dinosaur zoo that sits at a
monstrous undeniable in credible are
never-before-seen three percent not this
time
[Music]
Jurassic Island the dinosaurs ooh that
looks like it was made in iMovie and not
well this is Jurassic Island the
dinosaurs ooh made in 2015 June 11th
2015
and endless arrangements 9 3 3 3 9
different type of meat and plant eating
dinosaurs 15 different buildings
unrestricted construction of road and
animal enclosures which I would hope
they would not be restricted a variety
of challenges scenarios share your
favorite pictures of your park with your
friends excellent sound effects of 3d
animation oh boy alright here we go
really hard to build the simplest of
exhibits its tutorial muted it's
horrible and the dinosaurs don't even
want to stay in their cages but they did
a really good job on the Dino models
first thing I like this game I see a lot
of potential but the game in its current
state is not very great pros it's a
dinosaur zoo simulator the 2d graphics
are good cons you lose money far too
fast the controls are junk see this is
what I'm talking about this game is a
game and people are saying that you can
play the game it's just bad they say the
game could be good without a lot of work
but it's it's just it falls on its face
my baby ankylosaurus drowned itself in
the hole
move over Zook Tycoon we got a new best
game ever pros there are no pros cons
how do you make a fence at the moment to
be honest the game is pretty bad we'll
wait to see what they change to change
my mind we'll see red and June 10th 2015
but the thing is you shouldn't just take
my word for it and you shouldn't just
listen to the reviews that are there you
should try the game for yourself and
that's exactly what I am about to do so
without further ado I give you Jurassic
world
whatever the hell the name of the game
was so without further ado I give you
Jurassic world
so without further ado I give you
Jurassic Island the dinosaur zoo this is
my let's play
hello welcome use the build menu down
right for all the build options ok are
the controls
ooh fun ooh power level is low click the
build menu and build a power plant ok
build ooh ok
power levels low click the build menu to
build a power plane I know I'm getting
to it I don't what I I know power level
is low click the build menu to build a
power play
I know I know power plant got it here we
go power play on it I'm in it why can't
I build here is it the rocks whatever
power plant boom right click BAM baby
that's the power plan that's a weird but
okay whatever power love is look I just
built one
I literally just built one what do you
want for me where do I see the power
level where would I see the power well
water level of the zoo is low plea build
the water tower
alright what a doubt is baby boom boom
as a loud water tower start building a
road in cages for your dinosaur alright
okay Road Road build road elements by
clicking on the map tip tap right click
to remove road what okay to tap build by
clicking on the middle
[Music]
deep blue connect no new clicked no
connected I want you to connect you're
supposed to connect there that's Oh dad
that ain't right there that connected
ooh
BAM nope not know it any no you just i
guess that's as good as it's gonna get
okay got it and a cage okay that's those
are the lamps okay alright cage here we
go cage cage cage cage I'm building a
case from I've done it clean dirt hey
hey very clean dirt set for pop start
building a road in cages for you I built
it I built it I built it I think I built
it didn't I built it built hi babe I
have built a road and I've built a cage
and I'm pretty sure that's all you
wanted from me start building your I've
built a road I built one okay what is it
what is the rest of this zoos coin
research screens great is it raining
this is what rain is it's all grey my
power okay egg dyno here we go
boom oh hell yeah
look at that I got me a dyno is a
Dilophosaurus is definitely not a
Dilophosaurus all right oh I'm sorry
everybody I was just thrown for a loop I
scrolled the mouse wheel in a zoomed-out
I need a second to recover okay all
right so scroll in his zoom out scroll
out is zoom in got it that's
I've seen inverted controls I've never
seen inverted zooms I'm sorry okay
alright I'm better I'm fine I'm fine
okay water trough you want some water
baby you get yeah well yeah I get that
water oh is happy oh yeah that and hey
yeah this dino is so good I don't know
what everyone on Steam was tired about
I'm killing it what do I do
okay I map what map what what does this
do
what what is it what is oh you all right
there buddy
you okay okay I think that's someone
that's trying to get to my Park Luther
how are you catch Dinah's I gotcha oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] there you go I don't know
what this is all about what is this all
about what's this sign nope can't do
sign okay
what is this oh I have that now oh the
rain is gone I can see clearly I'm
really trying to understand what this is
guys I'm really trying to understand
this is something obviously this is and
this is a sign very clearly this is
supposed to be a sign but I neither
click is clicking what's that what is
that for
what's the flag in the circle why is
there just a shrub that poop did you
poop did you poop I deleted Road well
how did I delete Road I didn't even have
the road equipped get roads back clean
up poop I remember there was a way to
clean a poop but now I'm not recalling
what the cleanable is it clean up poop
poop gone baby book
this food farm egg my egg mine okay
that's fine
do I need to build a road are these
signs marking where the egg montanus
that's not that very clearly is not
that's fine I need to build my egg my
egg mine how about a food farm they're
perfect blammo yeah nor the Dementors
standing right there and how about
shrubbery do you like your shrubbery how
is anyone gonna get to my Island they
can't cross the river
they can't get to my Island how do I
make money
can't even click on this main bit this
looks important what is this power
I can't even click on power this is so
overlay for power God now that I'm
starting to understand and realize just
how much missing there's the economy
work where are you going what are you
doing I can't see you behind the flowers
what do you do I know
Oh tree node I know wait what wait left
right wait no hang on no no no no wait
no stop wait no stop right flowers left
dyno right trees wait stop did you poop
you just moved I can't see it sitting in
the flowers left dyno right tree left
should be Dino is flowers right died it
doesn't matter what button you press ok
that but this one this one does see
right left right left bench
I need a bench cuz I need to sit down
that's
that that perfect place for a bench
toilet so I can throw up no can't play
that no nope nope nope no toilets their
toilet their toilets ahem I have no
money fifty five hundred dollars left
I am NOT a fiscally responsible park
owner I have squandered my investment I
am in trouble and if the bank is coming
to get me I will buy Iraq about Iraq I
spend my last few dollars on a rock
sorry there bungo you ain't good oh you
like the rock oh good you're thinking
about poop oh the poop looks like a rock
I understand your wants and desires you
can't even go on a rampage just go on a
rampage does it matter if you're in the
cage or not does it not matter why did I
build the cage then how do I destroy oh
we got a dino on the run everybody guys
we got a Dyna
I get no money back for this obviously
there are still lights floating in the
sky oh okay so as we've discovered my
Park can't open because there is no one
here I can't build a road to get over
there I can't build on the water which
is logical and you can't connect to road
that was pre-made in the map if you
destroy fence some of the lights will
float I built this thing don't know what
it does
whoo oh I forgot I don't like this bar
so veiny why is that bar so veiny water
oh here's my oh here's my information I
found it Oh guys I found it egg add egg
to incubate start incubation oh oh how
do I get people in my
town you you you I can grab you I will
grab you I will grab you come to my zoo
come to my zoo come to my zoo what are
you doing with your life what are you
doing with your life why don't you don't
no I can't click on the bill I just I
see what the people meant it's like a
cardboard picture of food did it die did
my Dino just die space to roam get the
world what happened who did this to you
who hurt you it's raining cuz I'm sad
it's like a very realistic drawing of
food it makes you hungry and you think
you can eat it but then you go there and
you realize wait this is this is a
cardboard cutout I can't eat this this
is very clearly not food and that's what
this is oh my god from dust to dust
oh now it's an attraction
now people kids come on grab your
shovels and picks let's dig this fossil
out of here is the type of game that can
make you just go absolutely insane
because you could see like it's got all
the recipe of a game here you can see it
you can see it build power get water it
makes total sense but it's nothing it's
two-dimensional you look fast and you're
like there's nothing there somehow
they've managed to assemble a game into
a program that is not a
it's got all the pieces of a game but
it's not stitched nothing fair Oh God
just like I'm I'm literally like I'm
just blown away I'm blue this is clearly
this qualifies stop the music it's
driving me insane
this clearly qualifies as a game but it
is by every metric the worst it's not
even like you go like ah what a [ __ ]
game you go like what a [ __ ] game what
happened how did any developer make the
decisions to get to this you didn't play
test a single thing like as you were
building the game you clearly went well
that didn't work
alright time to work on a new feature we
need the bar but we need the water tower
we did the dinosaurs forgot about them
well whatever you know they don't need
to interact oh my god sorry I just had a
moment so yeah this is yeah this is just
yeah well you're their webpage up yeah
it makes sense
Twitter yup that makes sense
this is a video detailing the basics of
this game Road that's quick wait stop
the [ __ ] are those who the [ __ ] are
those the [ __ ] are those wait a minute
you stop in your tracks
that was not bad
that was not there what you can't do
that what is that for
[Music]
what is that for Oh
whoo-hoo
okay all right
[Music]
what
[Music]
I'm sorry um something in my brain just
like started snapping and I feel like I
wasn't very fair to that game but at the
same time it was very bad I don't even
know how to wrap a conclusion I feel I
feel I want to apologize I feel like I
let myself lose control and I stopped
being objective to what the game is
every single decision that was went into
making that game was so different from
what I would have assumed what would
happen that it broke my brain but I see
how this game got reviewed the way it is
there is every piece of a game in this
game
they just don't connect and in doing so
it is made the most bizarrely not
frustrating but just illogical
experience I've ever seen and therefore
I think that is well deserved a three
percent and I applaud the fact that it's
somehow managed to do it incredible I
don't know how you did it but you did it
if you want to play this game for
yourself I will link it in the
description oh yes I will and to the
developer look I don't mean to be
insulting with my criticisms but you
have to admit not a single thing made
sense in this entire experience I wish
it did I really wish it did but you lost
me at the scroll to zoom in and out that
just set me down the hill of rolling
into the shards of glass at the bottom
I'm sorry but everyone watching this
there is always lower games can always
get worse so maybe in another year I
will do another video like this and see
if the bar has been dropped any further
and we will explore the depths of how
far down a steam game can truly go
because there are two numbers below
three
to explore I don't think you can reach
zero but I've been surprised before so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments subscribe for more videos of
mine leave a like to hopefully avoid a
3% of our own and thanks everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
you